hey back up get on the ground
a California man calls for police to
shoot him after allegedly stabbing
multiple people with a screwdriver this
comes just minutes before an
officer-involved shooting stop it
come here
don't do it just before noon on May 30th
Long Beach California dispatch received
a 9-1-1 call reporting a man was
attacking people at a park Long Beach
if there's a guy with a knife trying to
stab people at Livingston Park with kids
in Long Beach the park in Livingston get
a police officers here he stabbed two
people oh my God he just stabbed the guy
right now the caller tells dispatch the
suspect later identified as 31 year old
Mario nahara is armed with a knife
investigators later determined he used a
screwdriver in the stabbings
God
right now
I'm breastfeeding my car he's
one of the fathers of a kid right now
give police here now Livingston Park
stabbing him he's stabbing him
he's wearing a black jacket jeans he's
probably five nine I can't get in there
right now because I have a baby and I'm
breastfeeding there's people running get
police officers multiple here now he has
a weapon he stabbed three people now and
his kids in the park and I just left
I'll leave here now now I'm working on
did you wanna leave your name
in all officials say nahara attacked
five people with the screwdriver
including a grandfather inside the park
and another man at a nearby restaurant
when the first Long Beach police officer
arrives on the scene nahara yells quote
shoot me
hey watch Crossfire hey don't come
towards me
hey get on the ground get on the ground
hey back up get on the ground
you know two boy eleven says he uh wants
to be shot
uh can you have a Wells Fargo closer
front door
Hey sir move move
hey get on the ground
next unit can you get a 40.
hey back up
hey
hey two boy eleven can I get the air
two boy eleven uh Mel Hispanic hey body
camera video shows nahara ignore the
officer's commands and approach another
person that's when the officer yells out
calling for nahara to back away but
hey step away from him get on the ground
hey next unit uh come off of Livingston
hey get on the ground my man
no one wants to hurt you
okay you need to get on the ground
two boy eleven uh he has that uh
knife in his right hand looks like uh
headed towards Livingston hey get on the
ground at this point additional officers
arrive on the scene on the ground
hey boo
let me know when you're ready
two boy eleven uh come off at second and
Livingston
um
he's just walking right now uh
looks like he's gonna start heading uh
northbound
hey um we got a victim right officers
follow as nahara walks into a driveway
and attempts to open a gate let's go
for unit 2.13 confirmed we do have a
victim
hey
hey watch when you're ready for that 40
let me know when you're ready
yeah come on come on
huh
okay let me know when you're ready
let's do it
drop it drop the knife
drop it all right
First Responders can be heard calling
for nahara to drop the weapon when he
refuses an officer opens fire
come here
body camera video shows the same moments
from another officer's perspective
hey
get on the ground now
let me know when you're ready
hit it up now
40 now
40 now 40 now
do it
drop it
drop the knife now
drop the knife drop it
come here
don't do it
after the shooting officers approached
nahara and begin first aid officials say
nahara was shot in the upper body he was
taken to the hospital and treated for
non-life-threatening injuries the other
victims only received minor injuries
nahara now faces multiple charges
including attempted murder and assault
with a deadly weapon right now he's
being held on one million dollars bail
the officer-involved shooting is still
under investigation by the Los Angeles
County District Attorney's Office
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie